بعد عام على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا يتخذ
الحديث عن التسلح منحا غير تقليدي مع
اعلان موسكو نقل اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه الى
حليفتها
سبق هذا التاكيد بريطانيا انها مستمره في
خطتها ارسال ذخائر لدبابات تشالنجر التي
تحمل رؤوسا مجهزه بيورانيوم مونوب
160 او البجاعه البيضاء كما يسميها الروس
وبلاك جاك كما يسميها الغرب تصنف بانها
اكبر واثقل طائره حربيه يبلغ طول القذفه
54 مترا ووزنها وهي فارغه 110 اطنان وهي
قادره على حمل اربعين طنا من الذخيره
والطيران لمسافه 12 الف كيلو متر دون
التزود بالوقود رغم التمتعها بنظام التزود
بالوقود اثناء الطيران
يمكنها ان تحمل 12 صاروخا نوويا قصير
المدى يضم طاقمها اربعه اشخاص هم طيار
ومساعد طيار وفني اسلحه وفني انظمه دفاعيه
صممت طراز الاول في ديسمبر من عام 81
وانطلق الانتاج الفعلي عام 84 تم تصنيع
حوالي 35 طائره منها حتى عام 2000 ثم قررت
موسكو اعاده انتاجها في عام 2015 بشكلها
الجديد وفي يوليو الماضي اجرت روسيا تجارب
لقاذفتها استراتيجيه فوق القطب الشمالي
وحلقت لمده سبع ساعات القذفه الاقرب
للمقارنه مع تي يو 160 هي نظيرتها
الامريكيه
بعيده المدى متعدده المهام بامكانها ان
تقوم برحله متواصله حول الكره الارضيه دون
توقف اذا تم تزويدها بالوقود في الجو
يمكنها ان تحمل 24 صاروخا مجنحا
وتعتبر الولايات المتحده متفوقه على روسيا
في فئه القاذفات الاستراتيجيه من حيث
الفئات والعدد
[موسيقى]